the swedish outlier sweden was the only
country here in europe this year that
did not implement
a nationwide lockdown to stem the spread
of the coronavirus
the approach has been controversial
because sweden's per capita death rate
is higher than its nordic neighbors
tonight infections are on the rise in
sweden
and restrictions are finally being
imposed
it's november one of the darkest months
of the year and this darkness is
unfortunately going to get worse
we're heading for darker times with the
rise in infections
the same goes for the world for europe
and for sweden
all of the indicators point in the wrong
direction the infection
is spreading quickly
well belgium has one of the world's
highest covid 19 death rates
a sharp increase in new cases has forced
the government to reimpose a partial
lockdown and as dw correspondent terry
schultz reports
the rules are being rigorously enforced
time's up for coronavirus rule breakers
in belgium
the warnings didn't work to convince
people to wear masks
limit gatherings to four people and obey
the evening curfew
so the next step is strict enforcement
by police inspectors like m lacroix and
kester otterberg
they've become the belgian authority's
last line of defense against the
sky-high
infection rate their weapon a 250 euro
fine
their orders are to accept few excuses
yes so he was not wearing his mask while
we are
passing there so it's a lot of money for
somebody that age
yes but everybody knows the rules it's
the same for everyone
it's not for us to judge he's able to
pay it or not so it's not our business
their business is to make sure that what
the prime minister has called the last
chance to get control of the virus isn't
wasted
the fear of having a ticket of having a
fine
is is going to stop some people
from committing infractions of course
and then we hope that the behaviors that
we are enforcing
are indeed stopping the disease there's
one area where officers
are being more tolerant now than during
the first wave of the pandemic
that's for people who can't stay home
because they don't have one
during the last lockdown many of them
received
fines plainclothes officer chris van der
jalte
is in a special police unit designed to
help get people
off the streets he and his colleagues
asked the corona patrols to take it easy
on the homeless this time around
the ideal scenario that would be that we
have place and shelter for everybody
but we're not in that situation for the
moment we have to be a little bit
flexible for those people and more
working like
sensibilize them to to work the mask to
keep them the
distance but they're part of the street
so
they're in the streets as a last resort
those who must or want to stay outside
can now get a document to show the
police and avoid a penalty
but vanderhaute agrees that for the rest
of the population
the tough approach is unfortunately
necessary
when you have people who doesn't want to
listen and always make like the main
same mistake same mistakes and mistakes
yeah you have to give them a fine you
know
they have to feel it somewhere hundreds
of those 250 euro infractions
are still being issued every week
according to the brussels police
on this night however by the 10 pm
curfew
downtown is deserted the officers say
they hope this means people finally
comprehend
just how bad the corona situation is if
everybody saw what's happening
really in brussels or in hospitals maybe
people
will take it more seriously and respect
all the rules the government's strategy
seems to be working
since the reinforced measures took
effect belgium is no longer in first
place for the worst rate of new
infections in europe
more on covert 19 now turkey is one of
many countries
seeing a big increase in the number of
new infections
but as in other places many are letting
their guard down
despite pressure from officials to stick
to the rules but opposition politicians
accuse the government of hiding the true
scale of the outbreak
as dw's yulia hahn reports from istanbul
the city of 16 million in which the
coronavirus is spreading
and one of the teams that are fighting
to stop it
is a dentist at least she was until the
pandemic started
she's been a contact tracer since march
one of around 35
000 in
and i sometimes wonder where this
pandemic is headed
but as a doctor i have a responsibility
i try to think positively
and knowing that i help people is what
motivates me
and keeps me going
[Music]
a tracing team manages around 10 house
calls a day
they work in shifts almost around the
clock
the goal is always the same track down
test and isolate those who've been
exposed to someone with covert 19
and all of this as quickly as possible
gurgun's first case today is the
collaxes olo family
the mother recently tested positive now
the father has symptoms too
if the test is positive gurgun will also
try to trace his contacts
the whole family has to stay at home for
the next 14 days
after each visit protective clothing has
to be changed
gurgun's job is time-consuming and
strenuous
but it's worth it she says
few countries expanded their contact
tracing capacity to the extent
turkey did these teams were key to
slowing the spread of the virus in
spring
health officials say but now like
elsewhere in europe the number of
infections here
is on the rise again as in many other
countries people's vigilance here has
slackened
in a recent survey more than half of the
respondents in turkey said the
coronavirus
does not affect or worry them
and critics also blame the government
for this lack of concern
because the health ministry no longer
reports the number of new infections
every day
but only the number of symptomatic
patients
of the opposition chp says the
government is hiding
the real scope of the pandemic islam
here in istanbul alone the number of
cases is 20
times higher than the tally from the
ministry of health
i'm saying this with regret but the
figures and information we are given
are not correct
on her next household
she does not want to take part in
political discussions
she knows the debate about the numbers
but doesn't want to get involved
that more and more people disregard the
coronavirus rules
frustrates her
it makes me sad we're putting so much
effort into this work
but what's the point if so many actors
if nothing can happen to them
hopes that she will soon be able to work
as a dentist again
but she also knows that her new job will
be needed
for quite a while
i'm joined now by dr emmanuel copa
bianca he's director of health at the
international federation of red cross
and red crescent societies
dr capo bianca thanks for talking to
deutsche weller
contact racing was seen as a key factor
to contain the virus earlier
in the year many countries did a good
job of expanding their capacity as we
just saw there in turkey but now
numbers are on the rise again is contact
tracing just not working
contact tracing remains key to uh stop
the epidemic and it always needs to be
looked with
testing and isolation and quality what
happens when the numbers are going up
so fast and then and the cases are so
large is that the system is simply
not functioning well anymore that
doesn't mean that contact racing or
testing is not important is that we need
to bring down the numbers
and then step up even further contest
contact racing and testing capacity
in the countries what do you say then to
those who claim that measures like
contact tracing
are hurting the foundations of democracy
i i totally disagree i think contract
tracing
is is key to stop the epidemic of course
it needs to be done
in with the absolute protection of the
data
and information of of people and that's
why
it's very important that this is done uh
by
professionals or people that are very
well well trained but
if we want to break this chain uh like
in any other
epidemics contract tracing like testing
like isolation and quarantine are
critical tools that we cannot uh do away
with
well let's move on to the vaccine which
um you know has raised hopes
in recent news the eu has agreed to buy
300 million doses of the vaccine
will we see will we see an even
distribution among countries
well there's been a lot of efforts to
put in place systems
to ensure equal distribution is unlikely
that we'll see that happening we need to
continue advocating that's what the red
cross
does for that to happen within countries
um so that the people who are
particularly at risk have it uh first
and also across
countries in in the world to make sure
that the low-income countries the
fragile settings are not forgotten and
the people in those countries are not
the last
uh to receive it and it's a it's a big
political
uh uh fight that we all need to really
uh go into to ensure that people have
access to vaccine in an equal way
indeed um in a recent interview you said
we ask governments to act with speed
courage and inclusiveness what do you
mean by that
speed because when when the numbers are
rising so fast
we need to move fast you need to put the
measures in place rapidly as lockdown
measures and
and the faster you are the more
effective these measures are
inclusiveness because you really need to
uh take care of the most
uh the most uh fragile ones and not only
for the virus also the most fragile ones
the most vulnerable ones from an
economic point of view
and the systems of social protection of
support for the categories of people
that are without work at the moment
is just as important as the physical
protection for the people who are uh
going to get uh get sick and so that is
what we are
really asking for speed and
inclusiveness at all levels in the
societies
all right emmanuel capo bianco director
of health international federation of
red cross and red crescent societies
thank you very much
thank you france is also
fighting to control a second wave of
covert 19.
daily infection numbers are the highest
in europe and yet the lockdown france
imposed is less strict than during the
first wave
the government is trying to strike a
balance between protecting health and
preserving the economy
but not everybody is happy about that
approach dw's lisa lewis reports from
paris
even under lockdown the french are
taking to the streets
as opposed to doing the first covet 19
wave
schools here are staying open but
teachers
don't feel safe we have between 20 and
25 pupils per class we are trying to
impose social distancing
but in our classrooms we can at most
have a distance of 40 centimeters
between each pupil
we were hoping the government would
dream for sanitary measures but they
haven't or at least not sufficiently so
we don't understand that we feel the
government
is abandoning us
they are getting support from their
pupils who have been blocking school
entrances
and posting videos online that show a
lack of social distancing
also unlike doing the first covet 19
wave more shops are open and large parts
of france's industry are still up and
running
and yet this is still one of europe's
strictest lockdowns
with people only allowed out one hour a
day
and only within a radius of one
kilometer of their homes
most french think the government was
right to confine them but
many criticized the method
i don't understand why big supermarkets
are no longer allowed to sell books
clothes or toys
just because small shops that sell the
same things are closed
the government is just not good at
explaining itself
this will cause lots of unemployment and
bankruptcies
why are they leaving big supermarkets
open by closing smaller shops
mega stores often take in hundreds of
clients and small shops only one or two
they are much safer and yet the
government is staying the course
even though the spread of the epidemic
has been slowing down
premiere we are seeing first indications
that the measures are producing an
effect
but it is too early to lift restrictions
the situation is still very grave
and the epidemic is continuing to gain
ground
the number of people in intensive care
is still going up with more than 93
percent of icu bets
now occupied by covet 19 patients the
government says
hospitals could reach the breaking point
sometime next week
and many people here fear now they might
have to spend christmas
on the lockdown let's take a look at
some other developments in the pandemic
germany has recorded nearly 22 000 new
coronavirus cases in the last 24 hours
the death toll in the uk has passed 50
000 that's higher than any other
european country
new restrictions have been announced in
new york
restaurants bars and gyms will have to
close at 10 pm
and private gatherings are now limited
to 10 people and the organisers of the
tokyo olympics next year
say athletes won't be required to
isolate for 14 days
the games have already been delayed by a
year
the recent news of a potential
breakthrough in the search for a
coronavirus vaccine couldn't
come soon enough recorded cases in
africa are nearing 2 million with the
infection rate accelerating in some
countries kenya has reported its highest
daily death toll from covert 19 with
24 people succumbing to the virus now
this number pales
in comparison to other parts of the
world but the increasing number of debts
comes as the rate of new infection
spikes across the country mostly
in nairobi and mombasa
the number of people infected with the
coronavirus in kenya
is sharply rising it's a worrying trend
in a nation where intensive care beds
are in short supply
authorities have started scaling up the
country's testing capacity
reporting more than 1300 new infections
on tuesday
without a vaccine and without any cure
in sight we'll probably be looking at
multiple peaks
over the next coming months kenya's
government brought back restrictions
last week
these include an overnight curfew from
10 p.m and bars and restaurants have
been ordered to close by 9 p.m
and like the first wave where people are
more uh
can i say worry about this thing and
they're also more cautious with the
second wave people drop their guards
down
so as a result you find the numbers
surging
the race against time has now resumed
for kenya to suppress the spread of the
virus
and avoid overwhelming its health
facilities
my first guest today is professor omo
anzala he's from the department of
medical
microbiology at the university of
nairobi
uh he specializes on infectious diseases
welcome to dw news africa
professor so on tuesday kenya reported
its highest death
toll since march and and cases in the
country
are also spiking why is this happening
now
yeah i think when we first got the first
case way back in march
and then we prepared very well for
you know the outbreak and we started
the response in terms of putting in
measures
some restrictions in nairobi and mombasa
travel restrictions and cuff use
and then risk communication i think what
we didn't do very well
we really didn't communicate very well
that this outbreak
was going to take a long time so
people started by social distancing
people went on to wearing masks
people went on to do sanitation and
hygiene
you know but with time fatigue are set
in and there's a lot of fatigue from
healthcare professionals fatigue
from the general public such that the
epidemic is actually taking longer
than anybody had they expected and
that's really where
the problems are that's where we are
beginning to see a spike
in infections i'll point out to our
viewers that you did have a mask on uh
just before we came off air
um but that professor and other measures
uh that the government has now recently
reimposed uh perhaps
do you reckon that that would be enough
to curtail
uh the spread of the virus yeah
those measures are actually the most we
can do
because what we are trying to do is uh
um i sit on the
on the covet task force that is advising
government
and our approach is to really balance
between interest in ensuring that life
goes on to some extent in terms of
commerce and industry
but at the same time we limit the spread
of covet
so really what we have put in place are
measures
that are still non-pharmaceutical
but really at the end of it all it boils
down
to individual responsible individual
responsibility
the curfew is still on uh to some extent
from nine o'clock not from ten o'clock
ten pm to you know five in the morning
uh we are not allowing people to move
around without
masks
you know gatherings but this boils down
to individual measures really there is
nothing more that the government can do
more than this okay all right professor
thank you so much i did have one more
question for you if you can answer this
one very quickly there's been news now
about a soon-coming virus what do you
make of that
the vaccine that is vaccine sorry
yes the vaccine no that is a game
changer for us
that is a major welcome what we also
want is african countries to be involved
for now
there are only two african countries
that are testing these vaccines
that is south africa and kenya that
started last week but we want to see
more
african involvement okay so that when
these vaccines are pronounced to work
then they will not only be working in
north america and europe
but they will have also been shown that
they are efficacious
in multiplicity of african countries
okay fantastic thank you so much
professor omo anzala
joining us from nairobi thank you
professor